.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich weiss noch,
es war an der Viehschau.
Die Kühe kamen irgendwann
zwischen etwa 8 und 9 Uhr
und wurden auf dem Platz angebunden.
Sie waren den ganzen Tag dort, konn-
ten sich nicht wirklich hinlegen
und sich nicht die Beine vertreten.
Sie hatten Hunger und Durst.
Dann kam das "Abzügeln".
Es ging schon beim Lösen
nicht ganz sauber zu und her.
Es herrschte Unruhe.
Die Zuschauer drumherum standen
etwas näher, als sie gesollt hätten.
Und eine Kuh
bekam einfach Angst und Panik.
Sie stieg auf die Hinterbeine,
wie man es von einem Pferd kennt,
das sich aufbäumt.
Da rannte eine junge Person rein.
Die Kuh kam mit den Vorderbeinen
auf sie runter,
mit viel Gewicht und Gewalt.
Sie warf ihn zu Boden
und verletzte ihn dabei schwer.
Es war ein schwerer Unfall.
Als ich mich umschaute,
sah ich tiefe Betroffenheit,
schon fast Panik.
Mitmenschen,
die wirklich reagierten,
etwas spürten
und das auch ausstrahlten.
Und ich merkte:
In mir drin spürte ich nichts.
Nichts.
Und in dem Augenblick
wurde mir endlich bewusst,
dass ich ein Problem hatte.
* Schmerzensschreie *
* Zischen von Blasterfeuer *
Ich bin Liby und ich war
zehn Jahre lang schwer gamesüchtig.
In dieser Zeit
gamte ich 18-19 Std. am Tag.
* Blasterfeuer *
Ich bewegte mich nur noch
das absolute Minimum.
Ich nahm extrem zu -
ich wog fast 160 kg.
Ich wusch meine Kleider nicht mehr,
ging nicht mehr duschen.
Es war eine Zeit,
in der ich einfach nur existierte.
Ich wusste lange nicht oder konnte
oder wollte nicht wahrhaben,
dass ich ein Problem hatte.
Und ich hatte absolut keine Ahnung,
wie schwer es sein würde,
aus dieser Sucht
wieder rauszukommen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Schlaggeräusche, Knurren *
Onlinegaming - ein Volkssport,
der alle Rekorde bricht.
Auch in der Schweiz
gamen drei von vier Jugendlichen
mehr als 1 Std. täglich.
Zwar sollen Computerspiele
auf viele Gehirnaktivitäten
positive Effekte haben,
aber vor Kurzem hat die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO
Gamesucht erstmals als neues
Krankheitsbild klassifiziert:
gaming disorder,
zu deutsch: Spielstörung.
Auch der 30-jährige Liby, der seinen
vollen Namen nicht nennen möchte,
hat viele Jahre gebraucht,
um sich eingestehen zu können,
dass er computerspielsüchtig ist.
Er hat bereits
mehrere Anläufe unternommen,
seine Spielstörung zu überwinden.
Jeder Rückschlag wirft die Frage auf,
ob seine Gamesucht
überhaupt heilbar ist.
Das versucht Liby nun in
einer Entzugsklinik herauszufinden.
Konzentrieren Sie sich
einfach mal auf das,
was Sie hier spüren.
Machen Sie sich bewusst,
dass Sie im Hier und Jetzt sind.
Nehmen Sie auch den Körper
auf dem Stuhl ein bisschen wahr.
Aber auch das,
was ich mit Ihnen gemacht habe.
Ist es okay, wenn ich Sie anfasse?
- Ja.
Mit der Hand. Spüren Sie sie.
Spüren Sie, dass Sie jetzt
im Hier und Jetzt sind.
Manchmal,
wenn man solche Gefühle wahrnimmt,
geht man ja
wie in die Vergangenheit.
Nachdem Liby als Zeuge jenes
schweren Unfalls an einer Viehschau
seine eigene Gefühllosigkeit
registriert hatte,
begann ein steiniger Weg.
Unter der Anleitung
von Psychologin Angelika Schneider
will er mit verschiedenen Techniken
seine Selbstwahrnehmung trainieren.
Das ist eine Schmetterlingsübung.
Wir überkreuzen die Hände.
Wieder so "Spürst du mich"-Zeug,
nicht wahr?
Ja, das ist etwas,
was ich durchaus brauche, weil ...
Wir können es probieren, oder?
Vielleicht
müssen wir die Einstellung,
die wir mal zu diesen Sachen hatten,
auch ablegen und merken:
"Wenn es mir was bringt,
dann kann ich das nutzen."
Ja.- Das eine
ist eben das mit dem Gefühl.
Ich spüre mich, wie ich stehe.
Warum kann Liby
keine Gefühle wahrnehmen?
Hängt dieses Defizit
mit seiner Gamesucht zusammen?
Wenn ja, wo liegen die Ursachen?
Und wann hat das alles begonnen?
Aufwühlend.
- Aufwühlend? Okay.
* Langsame, fliessende Musik *
Das ist mein Elternhaus in Nuglar.
Hier bin ich aufgewachsen,
habe also die ersten
zehn oder zwölf Jahre hier gewohnt.
In Nuglar war die Welt
noch relativ in Ordnung.
Ich war eigentlich
ein normales Kind.
Ich hatte es gut mit meinen Eltern
und meinen Schwestern.
Mein Vater war relativ abwesend.
Er arbeitete extrem viel.
Wenn er da war,
versuchten wir schon,
irgendetwas miteinander zu machen -
etwas zu spielen, etwas zu bauen.
Und die grosse Tanne hier draussen,
das weiss ich noch,
die hatten wir gepflanzt.
Wir konnten
von Jahr zu Jahr zuschauen,
wie sie wuchs.
Es gab viele Augenblicke,
in denen wir es
gut und schön miteinander hatten.
* Tiefe, sphärische Musik *
Meine Mutter, mein Vater
und meine beiden Schwestern
sind alle extrem arbeitsam,
extrem ehrgeizig, extrem fleissig.
Mein Vater ist ein, ja,
pedantischer Ordnungsmensch.
Es ging nicht ganz so weit,
dass er die Sachen mit dem Lineal
ausgerichtet oder abgemessen hat:
"So muss der Bleistift liegen."
Aber trotzdem: aufgeräumt, exakt.
Und ich war ein absoluter Chaot.
Also nach dem Motto:
"Ich räume auf,
wenn ich unbedingt muss."
Irgendwann
räumte ich selbstständig auf,
weil ich die Sachen für die Schule
nicht mehr fand -
die Schulbücher oder die Aufgaben,
die ich gemacht hatte.
Das ist etwas,
was er nicht nachvollziehen konnte.
Mein Vater war extrem sportlich.
Er trainierte verbissen.
Und ich nicht. Ich war unsportlich,
ein Schlaffi oder ein Warmduscher.
Das hat zu ziemlichen Konflikten
zwischen uns beiden geführt.
Irgendwann begann ich, mich
in den PC zu flüchten, ins Gamen.
Je mehr ich mich
absonderte und abschottete,
desto mehr kam ich mir
fremd und anders vor.
* Basslastige, sporadische Klänge *
Das ist "Ragnarok Online".
Da sehen wir jetzt gerade das,
was man dort die meiste Zeit macht,
also Monster jagen und besiegen,
um Erfahrung
und Ausrüstung zu sammeln.
Es geht bis Level 99.
Mit Level 95 hat man erst die Hälfte
der gesamten Erfahrung erreicht,
die man bis Level 99 braucht.
Ein Grossteil des Reizes beim Gamen
ist eigentlich
eine relativ klare Rollenverteilung.
Man weiss, wenn man
das und das tut, passiert das.
Das kommt dabei heraus.
Man tut dies und
es gibt dann jenes als Belohnung.
Im richtigen Leben
wusste ich nicht wirklich,
was ich machen wollte,
wo ich hinwollte.
Und ich hatte keine Ahnung,
wie die Leute reagieren würden,
wenn ich etwas tat.
Viele Jugendliche
haben sich beim Gamen
an eine
unmittelbare Belohnung gewöhnt,
während es im realen Leben
Durststrecken gibt
und der Erfolg ungewiss ist.
Ich erfuhr von meinem Vater
nicht wirklich Wertschätzung,
oder ich nahm es nicht so wahr.
Ich hörte praktisch nie
oder nur sehr selten:
"Gut gemacht", oder: "Toll!"
Im Grossen und Ganzen
hatte ich das Gefühl ...
Was ich wahrnahm, war,
dass von ihm Ablehnung kam.
Nach dem Motto,
und das sagte er manchmal auch:
"Du bist ein fettes Arschloch,
du bist nichts wert."
"Das packst du sowieso nicht."
Er hat vielleicht zwischendurch
schon etwas Positives gesagt,
aber daran kann ich mich
einfach nicht mehr erinnern.
Manche Eltern wollen ihren Kindern
jede Frustration ersparen.
Bei Liby
war es offenbar genau umgekehrt.
Trotzdem enttäuschte Liby
die hohen beruflichen Erwartungen
seiner Eltern.
Das ist die ehemalige JOWA.
Hier habe ich eine Lehre
als Lebensmitteltechnologe gemacht,
Fachrichtung Backwaren.
Es klappte die ersten paar Monate
eigentlich gut.
Ich stand pünktlich auf der Matte.
Irgendwann war dann ein schlechter
Tag oder schlechtes Wetter.
Und da dachte ich:
"Es ist scheisskalt,
ich möchte jetzt nicht raus."
Ich ging dann einfach nicht hin
und meldete mich nicht ab.
Ich sass dann zu Hause in der Wärme
beim Gamen oder vor dem Fernseher.
Und was mal
eine ganz seltene Ausnahme war,
wurde dann mehr und mehr zur Norm.
Das führte zu Hause
zu weiteren Konflikten.
Es gab Tage,
da kam ich nach Hause und merkte:
Je näher ich dem Haus kam,
desto mehr zog sich
mein Brustkasten zusammen.
Es war nicht mehr wirklich
ein Zuhause,
sondern mehr ein Ort,
an den ich zwangsweise gehen musste,
weil ich dort schlief.
Meine Eltern und meine Schwestern
waren irgendwann
nicht mehr meine Familie,
sondern, böse gesagt, der Gegner.
Ich versuchte dann, die Leere,
die ich spürte, mit Essen zu füllen,
und ging entsprechend auf
wie ein Ofenkuchen.
Dann wurde das Gewicht
ein weiterer Konfliktpunkt,
und dass ich mich selbst bediente -
beim Apérogebäck,
bei der Tiefkühlpizza -
also einfach im Kühlschrank.
Dabei war abgemacht,
dass ich das nicht tun würde.
Ich weiss nicht mehr ...
Es war im zweiten Lehrjahr,
als ich in der Nacht
mal wieder Tiefkühlpizza machte.
Mein Vater kam rauf und fand,
so gehe es nicht mehr weiter.
Ich hätte eine Woche,
um zu verschwinden.
Er habe sich eine Pistole gekauft.
Wenn ich in einer Woche noch da sei,
erschiesse er mich.
Es dauerte fünf Tage,
und ich war ausgezogen.
* Düstere Klänge *
Für den knapp 17-jährigen Liby
muss die Gamewelt
äusserst hilfreich gewesen sein,
um seine Verstossung von zu Hause
wegstecken zu können.
* Idyllische, mystische Musik *
Bei "World of Warcraft"
war ich primär Tank.
Als Tank ist man, wie der Name sagt,
ein Panzer und sorgt dafür,
dass die Schadenmacher
Schaden machen können,
ohne selbst umgehauen zu werden.
Schadenmacher können in der Regel
nicht viel einstecken,
während ein Tank viel einstecken,
aber wenig Schaden machen kann.
Gute Tanks waren relativ rar.
Wenn man es
einigermassen gut machte,
fand man immer schnell Anschluss
an eine Gruppe.
Und so nach dem zweiten oder
dritten Mal mit denselben Leuten
wussten sie:
"Auf den kann man sich verlassen.
Es funktioniert gut mit dem."
Liby fand
eine virtuelle Ersatzfamilie.
Im realen Leben kam er vorerst
bei einem Arbeitskollegen unter.
Die Berufslehre
brachte er trotz allem zu Ende,
fand aber anschliessend keinen Job.
Ab da gamte er nur noch.
Wenn ich gamte, gab es eigentlich
primär zwei Haltungen.
Die eine war
wirklich nah am Bildschirm dran,
den Fokus relativ eng.
Die andere
war einfach völlig zurückgelehnt.
Man sieht dabei etwas weiter.
Rechts in Griffreichweite hatte ich
die Flasche mit dem Getränk,
links hatte ich irgendwas zu Essen -
anfangs noch auf dem Tisch,
dann irgendwann
musste ich den Tisch ersetzen,
und dann war die Chipspackung
jeweils ans Stuhlbein angelehnt,
damit ich nur so
nach unten fassen konnte.
Und wenn dann mal etwas umfiel,
brach jeweils eine halbe Welt
zusammen, nach dem Motto:
"Uh, jetzt muss ich da hin
und kann doch nicht wegschauen."
(Mann) There's only one way
out of this, Alliance,
and it's through
that line of demons.
Cannons, lay down covering fire!
All forces, charge!
* Schlaggeräusche *
Ich hab vielleicht alle drei Wochen
mal das Gröbste weggeräumt -
in der Regel nicht ganz freiwillig,
sondern weil ich nicht mehr wirklich
vom Bett zum PC gehen konnte
oder anfing, das Bett vollzumüllen
und nicht mehr
hätte schlafen können.
* Brüllen *
Das wahre Ich, hier vor dem PC,
gab es nicht mehr.
Ich war gewissermassen
die Spielfigur.
Als Spielfigur
hatte ich die ganzen Probleme nicht.
Ich war nicht übergewichtig,
ich konnte mich bewegen,
konnte rennen.
Alles, was ich
im richtigen Leben nicht konnte.
Gamesüchtige sind sozial
weit weniger auffällig
als Drogen- oder Alkoholabhängige.
Oft wissen nur Eltern
oder Mitbewohner
um den Spielsüchtigen
hinter seinem PC.
Doch bei Liby wurden die Probleme
eines Tages aktenkundig.
Ich kann mich noch gut erinnern,
wie Sie im Oktober 2011
bei uns am Schalter
des Sozialdienstes erschienen.
Sie meldeten sich mit dem Kollegen
zusammen zur Sozialhilfe an.
Sie machten, ja,
keinen so zufriedenen Eindruck.
Der Kollege
sprach hauptsächlich für Sie -
worum es ging
und wie die Situation war.
Das war die Zeit, in der ich mich
wirklich stark abschottete.
Kapuzenpulli, die Kapuze immer oben.
Ein kleines Ziel darstellen,
so klein wie möglich wirken.
Ich musste nicht mit Leuten reden
oder auf sie zugehen -
nach dem Motto:
"So schnell wie möglich wieder raus
und nach Hause zum Gamen."
Ja, und die Wohnungssuche
stellte sich ja
als relativ grosse
Herausforderung dar.
Als Sie ganz frisch bei uns waren,
war das ja das Thema Nummer 1 -
dass Sie obdachlos waren.
- Ja.
* Fliessende Klänge *
Fast vier Jahre lang
kam Libys WG-Mitbewohner
für dessen Miete
und Lebenshaltungskosten auf.
Eines Tages
kündigte er die gemeinsame Wohnung.
Der Sozialdienst gab mir
eine Liste mit Telefonnummern
für Übergangs- oder Notfalllösungen.
So landete ich dann
in einem Hotelzimmer wie diesem.
Ursprünglich wäre das nur
als Übergangslösung gedacht gewesen,
bis ich
eine richtige Wohnung finden konnte.
Das war dann eben nichts.
Ich fand keine Wohnung
und war dann zwei oder drei Jahre
in dieser Kammer.
Die Kammer war dunkel, düster.
Ich merkte damals nicht, wie sehr
einem das aufs Gemüt schlägt.
Ich fing an, mehr und mehr zu gamen,
um einfach irgendwo anders zu sein.
Es ist ein Vorurteil, zu glauben,
dass Gamer weniger kommunikativ sind
als andere Menschen.
Aber ihr Spektrum im sozialen
Austausch ist sehr eingeschränkt.
Ha, ha, Noob!
* Düstere, rauschende Klänge *
In dieser Zeit
kommunizierte ich eigentlich
ausschliesslich über Teamspeak.
Da hört man nur die Stimme.
Die Mimik, die Gestik, das ganze
Nonverbale hat nicht stattgefunden,
das hat es nicht gegeben.
Das kam mir damals sehr entgegen.
Als richtigen, realen Menschen,
mit dem ich redete,
gab es eigentlich nur noch die Fall-
bearbeiterin des Sozialdiensts.
Man entschied dann, dass er in eine
Beschäftigungsstruktur gehen sollte,
eben zum Aufbau einer Tagesstruktur.
Nach einer gewissen Zeit
kam es da aber zum Abbruch.
Er erschien nicht mehr,
er meldete sich nicht mehr
und man konnte ihn
auch nicht mehr erreichen.
Es kam einige Male vor, dass wir
im Hotelzimmer vorbeigingen,
um ihn aufzusuchen,
weil wirklich nicht mehr klar war,
ob er noch existierte oder nicht.
* Kampfschrei *
* Düsteres Rauschen *
Dass ich nicht mehr rausging,
war z.T. auch aus Scham.
Nach dem Motto: "Ich stinke,
ich bin fett, aufgedunsen,
ich sehe aus wie eine halbe Leiche."
Bis zu einem gewissen Grad
war mir sicher bewusst,
dass irgendwas schieflief,
dass irgendwas nicht gut war.
Aber mich wirklich so hinstellen
und sagen:
"Nein, ich brauche Hilfe",
das konnte ich zu jener Zeit nicht.
Wir fuhren dann zum Hotel
und klopften an.
Meine Kollegin machte als Erstes
gleich mal einen Schritt rückwärts,
weil uns aus diesem Zimmer
ein wirklich sehr ätzender Geruch
entgegenkam.
Es flogen auch
so kleine Fruchtfliegen rum.
Wir sahen sofort, dass Lebensmittel
auf dem Boden rumlagen,
die vergammelt waren.
Das Zimmer war abgedunkelt.
Am Dachfenster, das er da hatte,
hatte er den Rollladen
runtergelassen. Es war ganz dunkel.
Und die Matratze,
auf der er schlief,
war durchgelegen
und auch ein bisschen verfärbt.
Es war ziemlich ...
Es war kein schöner Anblick
in diesem Zimmer.
Und das war dann eigentlich auch
der ausschlaggebende Punkt,
dass man sagte:
"Nein, so geht's nicht weiter."
Dann müssten Sie noch
die Karte in die Hand nehmen.
Habe ich denn die Karte gelesen?
- Sie haben die Karte gelesen, ja.
Ich hatte Ihnen
die Karte ausgedruckt.
* Sie lacht. *
Fünf Jahre ist es her,
dass Libys Sozialarbeiterin
einen Richtungswechsel initiiert hat.
Liby sollte
in ein neues Umfeld kommen -
in eine Gastfamilie,
betreut vom Projekt Alp.
* Sphärische, langsame Musik *
Mit 24 kam Liby
nach Aeschlen im Kanton Bern,
wo er bis heute auf dem Hubelhof
bei Familie Reusser wohnt.
Als ich auf dem Bauernhof ankam,
war mein erster Eindruck:
"Uh, da sind Leute. Da sind Kinder."
Und: "Uh, da kommt ein Hund."
Ich hatte sehr grossen Respekt,
schon fast Angst vor Hunden,
und dann kam da Raja
schwanzwedelnd an, völlig freudig:
"Hurra, da ist jemand Neues."
Es war extrem ungewohnt,
alles zusammen:
draussen, frische Luft, Sonnenlicht.
Ich hatte schon fast
einen Kulturschock.
Wir mussten uns zuerst
ein bisschen sammeln
ob der ersten Erscheinung von Liby.
Er war einfach ... Er stank,
er hatte keine heilen Kleider,
die Schuhe waren kaputt.
Er hatte sehr wenige Dinge -
keine Ersatzkleider,
keine Zahnbürste,
einfach wirklich nichts.
Er kam mit einem Plastiksack an,
einem Reserve-T-Shirt
und einem Pullover, mehr nicht.
Das war sein Hab und Gut, ja.
Wir hatten nicht erwartet,
dass das passieren konnte,
dass jemand so verwahrlosen konnte.
Und nicht nur äusserlich.
Auch innerlich war er,
glaube ich, sehr verwahrlost.
Als ich das Projekt Alp anfing,
nahm ich den Laptop mit,
das weiss ich noch.
Aber am Anfang
ist es eigentlich relativ klar:
Man gibt alles ab,
also Natel, PC, Laptop.
Die ersten paar Wochen
vermisste ich es nicht wirklich.
Ich wurde
durch die ganze Umstellung -
am Morgen aufstehen,
körperlich arbeiten
und v.a. unter Menschen sein
und mit diesen reden
und interagieren müssen -
völlig aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Ja, wir waren sehr erschrocken.
Er konnte einem
nicht in die Augen schauen.
Die einfachsten Regeln -
wie sagt man überhaupt Guten Tag -
mussten wir am Anfang üben.
Es klingt banal,
aber wann sagt man grüezi,
wann sagt man salü,
wann sagt man hallo?
Wann gibt man die Hand?
Also, die Hand
sollte man prinzipiell immer geben,
ausser mit dreckigen Fingern.
Wenn Kuhmist dran ist, sollte man
nicht unbedingt die Hand geben.
Und bei mir war es am Anfang so ...
Ich musste nachdenken,
was ich sagen musste.
"Wie grüsse ich jetzt? Moment,
ich darf nicht runter schauen."
"Ich muss in die Augen schauen,
ins Gesicht."
Aufstehen,
Mahlzeiten miteinander essen,
reden, Körperpflege.
Bei allem,
was wir ansprechen mussten,
wussten wir nicht,
wie wir das tun sollten.
Er ist ein erwachsener Mann.
Wie sollten wir ihm sagen,
dass er duschen sollte?
Da fand ich: "Den baden wir jetzt,
kleiden ihn frisch ein,
machen ihn zurecht
und dann wird das gut."
"Das ist ein junger, gesunder Mann."
Und Roland, mein Mann, sagte:
"Nein, nein, der bleibt bei uns."
"Das ist nicht
auf die Schnelle getan."
Ja, er hatte recht.
Liby ist immer noch bei uns.
Ja.
* Idyllische, langsame Musik *
Nach Jahren der Vereinzelung
plötzlich täglich umgeben
von einer sechsköpfigen Familie, das
war für Liby eine Herausforderung.
Aber die Chemie stimmt.
Auch die Kinder mögen ihn gern.
Liby selbst
musste sich den neuen Umständen
zunächst einmal körperlich anpassen.
Als du zu uns kamst, warst du
in einem schlechten Zustand.
Du schwitztest wie ein Bär.
- Ja.
Ohne Anstrengung
warst du patschnass.
Ich hatte permanent Angst,
du würdest umfallen,
wenn man dich überanstrengt.
Du hattest keine Ausdauer,
gar nichts.
Ich weiss noch:
Der kleine Spaziergang,
den ich mit Raja jeweils mache,
den Wald entlang hoch
und dann oben den Weg
und wieder runter ...
Das erste Mal kam ich oben an
und war völlig ausser Atem.
Aber dann, durch die Bewegung,
die du automatisch
zusätzlich hattest ...- Ja.
... weil du nicht mehr gamen
durftest, besserte sich das bald.
Ich fing dann schnell an zu lesen,
also eigentlich
fing ich wieder damit an.
Wenn ich eine freie Minute habe,
lese ich.
Ich besuche eine andere Welt.
Wenn ich lese, bin ich völlig
in den Wolken versunken.
Wenn man mich ruft, höre ich das
dann in der Regel nicht.
Man muss wirklich kommen
und mich schütteln: "Wir sind hier."
* Ruhige,
melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Schafft es Liby nach den
vielen Jahren im virtuellen Kosmos,
seine Aufmerksamkeit
wieder aufs reale Leben zu lenken?
Ich bin fertig.
Was soll ich machen?
Hast du den Zaun schon weggenommen?
- Nein. Soll ich noch abzaunen?
Das könntest du noch machen gehen,
aber du musst gut schauen.
Du musst den Zaun
dann wieder hintun.
Einfach den Telefonstangen entlang?
- Genau.
Sonst hauen die Kühe wieder ab.
Du musst aufpassen.
Mitdenken und dabei sein.
Diese Gedanken, die nirgends sind -
also jedenfalls nicht da -
sind immer wieder ein Thema.
Aber das ist auch,
weil du halt so abgelenkt bist.
Über deine Dinge nachdenkst.
Als wir
mit den jungen Rindern umzogen,
vom Moos hinten nach vorne,
fragte ich dich etwa dreimal -
das war im ersten Jahr,
das du hier warst ...
... ob überall Schnüre da waren.
Und dann war doch nicht überall
eine gespannt.
Und wenn wir
nicht so schnelle Kinder hätten,
wären sie irgendwo gewesen, ja.
Vielfach reagierst du dann auch
nicht so, wie wir es erwarten.
Kannst du dich noch erinnern?
Als du die Schnüre nicht
gespannt hattest, sagten wir:
"Liby, so geht's nicht."
Weisst du noch,
wie du da reagiert hast?
Nein, aber ich nehme an,
dass ich nicht reagiert habe.
Es ging links rein und rechts raus.
Ja, und dazu
ein Lächeln auf den Lippen.
Wir wussten nicht,
wie wir dich jetzt nehmen sollten,
was wir tun sollten.
Eigentlich war es ein Fehler,
den du gemacht hattest,
und du hast uns angegrinst.
Es ist einfach nicht greifbar.
Ich weiss nicht, was du denkst,
wenn du einfach immer
dieselbe Mimik hast
oder eben so ein leichtes Grinsen.
Dann wissen wir nicht:
Hat er jetzt begriffen,
was wirklich passiert ist?
Wenn du nicht angemessen ...
Also, angemessen reagieren ...
Traurig sein,
wenn etwas traurig ist.
Wenn du bei einem Todesfall
kondolierst und grinst ...
Das hatten wir ja auch.
Du hast dann so ein leichtes Lächeln
und weisst nicht wirklich ...
Ja, wie verhält man sich
oder was soll man ausdrücken?
Genau, weil du es auch
irgendwie nie gelernt hast.
Du hast schon so jung
am Computer geklebt.
Du hast gar nie gelernt,
wie man sich richtig verhält.
Wir haben dich
auch nie glücklich gesehen.
Du warst vielleicht schon glücklich,
aber sehen konnten wir es nicht.
Es dauerte nicht Monate,
sondern eher Jahre,
bis wir dich
zum ersten Mal lachen hörten
und das Gefühl hatten,
es war ein Lachen von Herzen.
* Flacher, anhaltender Ton *
Seit seinem Schlüsselerlebnis
auf der Viehschau weiss Liby,
dass ihm der Zugang
zu seinen eigenen Gefühlen fehlt.
Er glaubt, dass ihn diese Erkenntnis
der Heilung seiner Gamesucht
entscheidend nähergebracht hat.
Als ich zu gamen anfing,
blieb meine emotionale
und soziale Entwicklung stehen.
Gut, das merkte ich selbst nicht.
Ich war mir selbst gegenüber
völlig blind.
Ich hatte auch nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich keine Emotionen hatte
oder ich sie nicht spürte.
Für mich
war es einfach so normal geworden.
Es hat ja auch lange gedauert,
bis du es selbst gemerkt hast.
Wir haben dir das schon gesagt.
- Aber es ist nicht angekommen.
Auch in alltäglichen Situationen
war es für Liby anfänglich schwierig,
nicht vor seinen Gefühlen
davonzulaufen.
Die Idee war, dass du
sechs bis acht Wochen hier sein
und so wieder eine Tagesstruktur
erhalten würdest,
und dann -
glaubten die vom Sozialdienst alle -
könne man dich wiedereingliedern.
Du könntest wieder arbeiten gehen.
Du hast auch gesagt,
du wolltest wieder arbeiten gehen.
Und so ging das dann los.
Du hast dich ...
... ein bisschen zurechtgemacht,
damit es gut wirkt, aber ...
Du hast versucht, dich für
einen Praktikumsplatz zu bewerben.
Uns hast du gesagt,
du hättest dich beworben,
aber beworben
hattest du dich nirgends.
Dann hast du
das Praktikum angetreten -
irgendwo auf einem Bänkchen.
Mit einem Buch zum Lesen.
- Genau.
Das Praktikum wäre eigentlich
bei einer Bäckerei gewesen,
die bekannt dafür ist,
dass sie Meringues herstellen.
Du bist ganz durchfroren
nach Hause gekommen
und wolltest uns erklären,
dass man diese Meringues
bei kalter Luft trocknet.
Da war für mich klar:
Das stimmte nicht.
Ich rief am nächsten Morgen
deinen Betreuer an und sagte,
er müsse diese Bäckerei anrufen
und fragen,
ob da wirklich ein Praktikant sei
und ob sie schon mal
von dir gehört haben.
Danach war es klar.
Da merkten wir:
Da sind ganz viele Geschichten,
die nicht stimmen.
Da gibt es noch mehr Probleme.
Von da an war ganz klar,
dass Liby noch lange
hierbleiben würde.- Ja.
Er hat ein Bild im Kopf,
von dem er glaubt,
das würden wir gerne sehen.
Er überlegt sich ja wirklich:
"Was wollen diese Leute
jetzt hören?"
"Das, was sie hören wollen,
erzähle ich ihnen jetzt."
Dann lassen Sie mich wieder in Ruhe.
Dann habe ich keinen Konflikt.
Wenn ich sage:
"Nein, ich will nicht",
muss ich mich vielleicht erklären.
Die Angst oder der Unwille,
das zu tun, war grösser,
als zu sagen:
"Nein, ich will einfach nicht."
Es war einfacher, Ja zu sagen
und dann irgendetwas zu fingieren,
etwas vorzumachen,
als mich wirklich hinzustellen.
* Schwebende, langsame Musik *
Vor schwierigen Situationen flüchten.
Alles vermeiden,
was innerliches Unbehagen
oder überhaupt eine Gefühlsregung
hervorrufen könnte.
Diese Muster scheinen sich Liby
seit seiner Jugend
regelrecht eingebrannt zu haben.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Oder hat umgekehrt erst die Sucht
solche Verhaltensmuster geprägt?
Mit anderen Worten:
Ist die Gamesucht das Grundproblem
oder ist sie bloss eine Reaktion
auf andere Schwierigkeiten?
Ich hätte wirklich gerne mal
mit der Mutter oder dem Vater
gesprochen, um zu hören,
wie Liby als kleines Kind war.
Wie war er,
bevor er den Computer bekommen hat?
Wir kennen einfach eine Seite.
Wir haben oft gesagt, wir würden
gerne auch die andere Seite hören.
Denn es gibt nicht immer nur
Schwarz und Weiss,
es gibt auch ganz viel dazwischen.
Es wäre spannend, von ihnen
zu hören, wie es wirklich war,
oder sich halt selbst
ein Bild machen zu können
von diesen zwei Geschichten,
die man gehört hat.
Wir hatten nie wirklich Kontakt
mit seinen Eltern.
Seine Eltern
möchten diesen Kontakt nicht.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Für ihn ist Rölu
natürlich sehr wichtig.
Er schaut sehr zu ihm auf,
haben wir das Gefühl.
Und Rölu ist einer,
der auch sagen kann:
"Hey Liby,
heute hast du das super gemacht."
Oder: "Schau mal, wenn du es
so drehst, ist es so gut."
Das braucht Liby.
Er braucht das sehr,
diese männliche Bezugsperson,
die ihm Respekt entgegenbringen
und ihm sagen kann: "Du bist gut."
Ich glaube, er strebt schon danach,
dass sein Vater ihn anerkennt.
Für ihn wäre es wohl
eine grosse Erlösung,
wenn sein Vater
ihm einfach sagen könnte:
"Du bist gut.
Es ist gut, wie es ist."
Das würde vielleicht
viel Druck nehmen.
Wir als Familie
sind die Bezugsfamilie.
Es braucht jedes Kind,
das ihn irgendwo herausfordert.
Es braucht alle von uns.
Das ist wichtig, ja.
Das Projekt Alp hat etwas mehr
als zweieinhalb Jahre gedauert,
und danach hatten wir das Gefühl,
es laufe relativ rund.
Er brauche nicht mehr
die gleiche intensive Betreuung.
Aber dann kam die grosse Frage:
"Wo geht Liby denn hin?"
"Allein leben kann er nicht."
Da kam der Betreuer
noch einmal auf uns zu,
ob wir uns vorstellen könnten,
Liby bei uns zu behalten.
Und so konnte sich dann
das Projekt Alp zurückziehen,
und jetzt läuft das nur noch
über den Sozialdienst, genau.
Und die Gamesucht?
Hat sich Liby im gesunden Umfeld
davon befreien können?
Ist das Verlangen nach Ablenkung
und Verdrängung verschwunden?
* Dramatische Musik, Schreie *
* Kampfgeräusche *
* Elektronisches Piepen *
Ich game immer noch, aber selten.
Also seltener
oder zumindest deutlich weniger.
Es ist eigentlich
mehr ein Zeitvertrieb.
40, 45 Min. bis 1 Std. am Tag.
Ich muss sagen,
da das so ziemlich alles ist,
was ich online mache, ist das
eigentlich ein vernünftiger Umgang.
Ein vernünftiges Ausmass.
Dass er gamt, wissen wir
erst seit einem Monat offiziell.
Bis vor einem Monat
hat er fest behauptet,
dass er online
nur Geschichten liest.
Gewusst haben wir es schon,
aber zugegeben hat er es erst jetzt.
Das zeugt ja auch von einer Sucht,
wenn man etwas nicht zugeben kann.
Wir haben dich oft
darauf angesprochen
und hatten immer das Gefühl,
es stimme etwas nicht.
Aber du hast immer Nein gesagt,
und wir konnten es
einfach nicht beweisen.
Und dann ... Es gab eine Situation,
als du über unser WLAN ...
Du hast das gehackt
oder bist einfach reingekommen.
Wir wussten das,
konnten es aber nicht beweisen.
Bis mal alles zusammengefallen ist.
Ja, stimmt.
Wir mussten dich überall,
bei allem immer so ...
Als du ganz
in die Ecke gedrängt warst
und keine Fluchtmöglichkeit
mehr hattest,
bist du gekommen
und hast es erzählt.
Dinge, die wir eigentlich
schon lange gewusst haben.- Ja.
Ja, also selbst die Sachen
etwas beschönigen, nach dem Motto:
"Ja, es ist nur
ein einmaliger Ausrutscher."
"Einmal macht nichts, ein zweites
Mal ist auch noch nicht so schlimm."
"Ja, es ist doch eigentlich
nicht so tragisch."
Oder: "Jetzt waren es 2 1/2 Std.,
das ist immer noch besser
als 5 Std."
In etwa so.
Nicht wahrhaben wollen,
dass man etwas falsch gemacht hat.
Das ist ein relativ tief
eingegrabener Automatismus.
Man merkt meistens schon am Morgen,
wenn er zum Frühstück kommt,
wie viel er online gewesen ist.
Auch wenn er unterwegs war
und am Abend nach Hause kommt,
merken wir in der Regel
ganz genau daran,
was er erzählt
und wie er es erzählt,
ob es wieder ein Tag war,
an dem er stark über seine
Onlinesachen nachgedacht hat
oder sogar online war.
Und Herr Gurtner, der Psychologe,
hatte dann wirklich auch das Gefühl,
es gehe zu viel zugrunde.
Es hängt ja auch sehr viel daran:
seine Finanzen, das Essverhalten,
das gesellschaftliche Verhalten.
Er geht in die Männerriege,
er geht in den Samariterverein -
all das hat auch angefangen,
darunter zu leiden.
Er hat sich
überall wieder zurückgezogen,
wieder angefangen, Mauern zu bauen.
Alles, was man vorher
über Jahre aufgebaut hat,
ist langsam wieder zusammengestürzt.
Kommt!
Seit ein paar Monaten
besucht Liby nun wöchentlich
in der Klinik Selhofen
eine neu gegründete
Selbsthilfegruppe für Onlinesucht.
Parallel dazu,
dass er uns allen weismachen wollte,
er arbeite jetzt an diesem Problem,
kaufte er sich heimlich
ein noch leistungsfähigeres Natel,
und das auf Pump, weil er das Geld
überhaupt nicht hatte.
Für uns war da wie klar, dass dieses
Problem einfach noch riesig ist.
* Dunkle Melodie *
Seine Beiständin, Frau Imboden,
meinte dann,
wir sollten Bedingungen stellen,
damit er bei uns bleiben kann.
Wir haben die Bedingung gestellt,
dass er einmal für einen Monat
alle seine Geräte abgeben muss,
damit er und wir schauen können,
ob sich etwas verändert.
Das war heftig.
Es war ein Entzug
wie bei einem Alkoholiker,
nur dass es nicht körperlich war.
Aber er war gereizt,
manchmal musste er weinen,
dann war er wieder wütend.
14 Tage lang
durchlebte er alle Gefühle,
die man durchleben kann,
und zwar heftig.
Das hätte ich nicht erwartet.
Könnte man das nicht
sogar positiv sehen?
Endlich kommen Gefühle hoch
und werden für Liby wahrnehmbar.
Doch dann kommt ihm
seine Esssucht wieder in die Quere.
In der Speisekammer
fehlen eines Tages Würste,
die zum Verkauf bestimmt
gewesen wären.
Für Familie Reusser ist nun klar:
Dieses Ereignis
muss für Liby Konsequenzen haben.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
- Guten Morgen.
Vor sechs Wochen hatten wir
unser letztes Standortgespräch.
Sie, Herr L., hatten da gerade einen
Monat ohne Internet hinter sich.
Für Sie war klar, dass Sie
Ihre Geräte zurückhaben wollten.
Wir haben aber
verschiedene Abmachungen getroffen.
U.a. haben wir vereinbart,
dass die Verantwortung für die Nut-
zung Ihrer Geräte bei Ihnen liegt.
Eine weitere Vereinbarung war,
dass Sie bei der Wahrheit bleiben.
Du, Sandra, hast gesagt,
ihr als Gastfamilie habt in letzter
Zeit mehrmals darüber diskutiert,
ob ihr noch der richtige Platz
für Herrn L. seid.
Er wohnt jetzt
seit über fünf Jahren bei euch,
und ihr habt den Eindruck,
dass sich wenig verändert hat,
v.a. auch bei der Onlinesucht.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
es ist das grosse Ganze.
Online ist ein grosser Teil davon
und schützt davor,
irgendetwas zu spüren.
Es ist also viel passiert -
wir haben Dinge entdeckt,
die so
nicht hätten passieren sollen.
Und die Dinge, die du getan hast -
es ist nie eine Entschuldigung
oder so gekommen.
Du bist in dein Zimmer gegangen,
hast dein Handy rausgeholt,
und dann hast du es vergessen
und es war erledigt.
Und Reussers können jetzt machen,
was sie wollen.
Und wie erleben Sie das jetzt
in der Therapie?
Ich finde, es ist schwierig,
Herrn L. zu spüren.
Ich habe auch häufig das Gefühl -
das haben Sie auch schon gesagt -
dass er einfach das sagt,
was man von ihm erwartet,
aber ich spüre es nicht.
Ich spüre auch
keinen Veränderungswunsch.
Gerade mit dem Filmen,
als ich mich den Problemen stellen,
also das Ganze
wieder aufarbeiten musste ...
Am Sonntag, als wir in Nuglar waren,
haben wir über den Konflikt
mit dem Vater geredet.
Ehrlich gesagt, an dem Tag
war ich ziemlich überfordert.
Am Morgen war ich nicht wirklich ...
Ich stand ein bisschen neben mir.
Oder nicht nur ein bisschen neben
mir, sondern wirklich neben mir.
Die Dreharbeiten rütteln auf,
aber gleichzeitig
steht der Wurstdiebstahl im Raum.
Sandra Reusser pocht darauf,
dass Liby diesem Thema
nicht ausweicht.
Wie sollen wir dir vertrauen?
Müssen wir von nun an den Keller
und jede Ecke abschliessen?
Sag du mir,
wie wir dir vertrauen sollen.
Wie sollen wir nach dem
zusammen weitergehen?
Wenn du
nicht einmal das Gefühl hast -
also, das ist der Eindruck,
den wir von aussen haben -,
dass du einen Fehler gemacht hast.
Wenn du nicht mal kommst,
um mit uns zu reden.
Ich fand immer,
es passe doch gerade nicht.
Oder es sei nicht gemacht
mit nur: "Es tut mir leid."
Was erwartest du jetzt von uns?
Was sollen wir jetzt machen,
damit wir sicher sein können,
dass das, was wir sagen,
auch funktioniert?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Doch, eigentlich wäre es ja
die klare Schlussfolgerung,
dass das jetzt das Ende ist.
Für uns war klar ...
Ich habe mit Verena telefoniert.
Es war klar, dass wir sagen,
dass eine Anschlusslösung
gesucht werden muss.
Du darfst für die Tagesstruktur
weiterhin zu uns kommen,
aber irgendwo
müssen wir wir bleiben.
Und durch das, was wir jetzt merken,
eben über diese Filmerei ...
Wenn wir sehen,
wie du durch den Wind bist,
wissen wir,
dass es der falsche Weg wäre,
wenn wir Liby
jetzt noch das Zuhause nehmen.
Dann geht nichts mehr.
Er ist jeden Abend
reingekommen, hat sich hingesetzt
und musste einfach erzählen.
Und da kommt viel.
Aber es muss
irgendeine Konsequenz haben.
Für mich ist das ganz klar.
Du musst lernen, ehrlich zu sein.
Rölu hat es dir gesagt:
Es ist nicht fünf vor zwölf,
es ist zwei vor zwölf.
Eine kurze Zeit
war es sogar fünf nach.
Die Filmleute retten dir gerade
den Arsch, böse gesagt.
Weil wir wirklich gemerkt haben:
Wenn wir ihm das jetzt nehmen,
nehmen wir Liby alles.
Also auch das Wohnen,
also nicht nur ...
Also, wenn wir jetzt sagen,
dass er raus muss ...
Was passiert dann mit dir?
Das geht nicht gut aus.
- Das nimmt dir den Boden.
Das haben wir jetzt gespürt.
Es scheint mir auch schön,
dass ihr auch bereit seid,
darauf zu reagieren.
Dass du sagst:
"Wir können es nicht so durchziehen,
wie wir es eigentlich
beabsichtigt haben."
Aber ich denke auch, dass man jetzt
die Krise nutzen sollte,
um wirklich
neue Schritte einzuleiten.
* Langsame, ruhige Musik *
Klinik Selhofer, Schneider.
- Guten Tag, Frau Schneider.
Ich bin bis anhin ambulant
in die Selbsthilfegruppe gekommen.
Ich möchte stationär kommen.
Okay.
Wie sieht es jetzt aus bei Ihnen?
Was wurde besprochen?
Auch in der Familie - Sie haben ja
einen Familienplatz, oder?
Jawohl.
Es sind noch
zwei, drei Dinge passiert.
Ich habe mich beim Essen selbst
bedient, entgegen der Abmachung.
Das ist auch herausgekommen.
Ich habe es mir ein bisschen einfach
gemacht mit der Entschuldigung.
Mich einfach
ein bisschen abgeschottet.
Und, ja ... Selbst werde ich es
wahrscheinlich nicht packen.
Okay.
Im Moment sind die Wartelisten ...
Ich würde mal sagen,
dass wir bei Ihnen schon mit zwei
bis drei Wochen rechnen müssten.
Jawohl.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Burgdorf, resp. Selhofen ...
Ich weiss nicht, was mich erwartet.
Ich erhoffe mir,
irgendwann vernünftig
mit meiner Vergangenheit
abschliessen zu können,
sodass es nicht wieder so ist,
wenn irgendetwas
ein bisschen angekratzt wird,
dass ich selbst schon merke, dass es
vielleicht eine Woche dauern würde,
dass ich wieder
18, 19 Std. am Tag game,
um mich nicht
damit auseinandersetzen zu müssen.
Es gibt in meinen Augen immer noch
ein Stigma, stationär zu gehen.
Es ist ein Zeichen von Schwäche.
Und das sind andere Leute.
Auf der anderen Seite ...
Es ist nötig. Ich brauche das.
Libys Psychologe hat immer gesagt:
"Wie lange es auch dauert,
bis jemand am tiefsten Punkt ist,
es dauert doppelt so lange,
bis man wieder gesund ist."
Und wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass Libys Probleme mit
vielleicht zehn angefangen haben -
mit 24 ist er hier hingekommen ...
Ja, dann dauert es noch einen
Moment, bis er wirklich gesund ist.
* Melancholische Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020